we love having this guy on it's been a
while we fell in love with him first
fell in love with him when he was in
stand by me and then of course he had us
at hello in jerry maguire and now he's
one of the co-hosts of the talk which is
celebrating season 12 with a rock the
block party outdoors on the cbs studio
center residential street in studio city
california coming up monday september
13th the season premiere
uh of the talk is at 2 3 eastern time
starring in part the man who's on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line here on
the rich eisen show jerry o'connell how
are you jerry uh oh is jerry there yes
mr eisenhower i don't know if you heard
my my whole big to-do introducing you i
don't know if you heard all that or not
i did it was really uh it was really
quite moving thank you i wish you could
put me in a better mood but um
we're only one game into this fantasy
football season okay so i know you with
someone who uh i would always come on
the nfl network and talk about fantasies
in the infancy of fantasy football sir
but um
i i i might have to quit it all all
altogether we're only one game into the
fantasy football season and already my
children
i picked my children up yesterday from a
volleyball practice that they're in
don't get too excited they're not very
good but at least they're out of the
house
yes and um
they said you know daddy why are you so
quiet why are you so you you seem
depressed yes
and i looked at them and i said because
i'm playing someone who's playing not
only gronkowski but also chris godwin
okay so now um is is that is that
fantasy football and i said yes and they
said why do you play every year daddy it
makes you so sad
and mouths
here we are again i i'm i'm literally
we're one hour into the season and
already i'm
i'm angry and sad well let let me just
if you don't mind jerry o'connell um to
borrow some phrases from your world in
history
um
let me
help me help you that's number one
and um right now
you gotta suck it up
because it sounds like you're getting
two for flinching right now on your
fantasy and you can't have that
jerry
come on
it's a long marathon
okay you know i don't go jerry
but i rode with chris godwin every year
and then of course last year i ride with
him and he only plays a handful of games
he has finger surgery and when he does
start he's got antonio brown in there
all of a sudden and it's not happening
and then of course the one day i play
against him in fantasy football
he has
25 points
who went in the last round of every
league and no one would touch him has
not won but two touchdowns in the first
hour of football this year i can't
handle fantasy football any longer
richard jerry
jerome it's destroying my life jerry
o'connell let's let's about jerry
o'connell here on the roof let me give
another proper introduction the uh one
of the stars of the talk on cbs which is
uh celebrating a season 12 premiere on
monday september 13th with a neat
outdoor bash nfl network alum
joining us
just handing him my phone and saying
please fix my lineup that's upside down
yes these i'm stopping these websites
all of my salary to automatically set my
um
rosters
oh my goodness don't even get me started
i had my my big pick up my big sleeper
was gus edwards can you believe i'm
watching my children poorly play
volleyball yesterday
and then my alarm start my my phone
starts dinging i thought it was an amber
alert but it's there to tell me that gus
edwards is no longer playing this season
so i go immediately to pick up le'veon
or to go pick up tyson
and he's already gone in my leagues
thank goodness
uh thank goodness former nfl network
alum michael fabiano texted me and said
pick up latavius now and yes i finally
got him and i'm gonna be starting him
but just let you know i'm starting
latavius in my flex and we're one hour
into this season i can't take it anymore
jerry i can't take jerry o'connell here
on the rich eisen show mercedes-benz
vans phone line so hold on a second
jerry
a flex that's
i mean come on you got to have another
receiver or some tight end somebody that
you could start it flex
it's a 14 it's it's it's a 14 team
league everyone is gone these
these i hope i'm not offending anyone
these
mental cases that i play with in this
league are just they immediately
everyone is gone the only one i could
play possibly instead of latavius is
alan lazard who's got a bad one but you
just don't want to be you got to go no
but he just that you don't want to be
opening with an allen lizard no offense
to
mr lizard he's a great receiver he's fun
to watch he plays with a lot of passion
to have
to watch play them um
i'm gonna play latavius i'm going to i'm
going to roll the dice i have a thing
where i have to have ravens ground game
on all of my fantasy teams
and i thought gus edwards was going to
take me to the championship circle
but unfortunately um
[Music]
it's going to be me and latavius well
let me let me let me help you out here
let me help you out here then okay
jerry o'connell here on the rich house
show uh latavius murray if i'm not
mistaken was born into the league by the
oakland raiders and he's going to be
taking on the las vegas raiders maybe he
wants to teach him a little bit of a
lesson i don't know go alan lazard
that's my two cents to you who else is
this league anybody we know anybody else
anybody we know anyone we've heard of
jerry uh named these are all civilians
there is one non there is one
uh an actor by the name of anson mount
he plays oh yeah we know who he is
captain pike on uh on the new star trek
show he was also in a show called hell
on wheels yeah okay um
i was making a lot of fun of him
um
we were in an auction draft which took
17 hours
jerry jerry stop right there you got to
get out of this league
okay your children's your children
your
your children are the greatest
reflection of you and your lovely wife
you know that already jerry okay
you know that already your children are
saying daddy what's wrong that's an
alarm bell that's going off it's it's
the there's there's smoke in the house
you got to get the hell out
and that's
17 hours you've got a life jerry you've
got a job you've got children what is
the matter with you i'm so happy that
the season i'm just so happy that the
season has finally started you know when
i i had six drafts this week and when i
have a draft because i have to have all
these other
ancillary sites that tell me rankings
that i sync up with my draft yes no one
in my house can also use the internet
the internet is only for me the children
can't use the tick tock they can't be
snapchatting my wife cannot be online
um you know shopping searching streaming
there's none of it i literally take all
their devices i shut them off and i put
them in a safe
and it's just me
and a 17-hour auction drive well i think
we must live in the same neighborhood
because a lot of times this week my
internet's dipped out in the
neighborhood maybe it's just you sucking
it from all of lost greater los angeles
jerry
maybe yeah i was um oh my god a little
upset in another league i had this whole
thing i was taking austin eckler in all
my leagues in the first round and um my
internet uh crapped out so i ended up
with nick chubb but uh good i tried to
offer a few trades nothing happened so
i'm rolling with chubb in one of my
leagues as well all right so who else is
in those leagues give me that give me
the one with the least non-civilians
you know it's not exactly in a league
with a group of your friends um i'm in a
league with the former co-stars of the
show the league okay everyone's in it
except for your friend uh jeff schafer
who was the creator of the league
and um all right you have to say you
know not to smack talk but those cast
members who are on the league
big they're not good they don't know
much about the national football league
[Music]
now that said i can't talk too much
smack
i um
this is the most embarrassing
point of my life i mean this is really
this is this is a low point in my life
last season
i came in last in their league
oh so what do you have to do what you
have to do
i i had to do the punishment it is yes
uh we i realized that um
i realized that all uh gambling is wrong
and bad but there is a financial
punishment okay at the end it's nothing
insane okay not like the show
embarrassing because
i it's more embarrassing because i've
lost the people who
you know are trying to draft thurman
thomas in the first round they just have
no
clue
what happened
and
the fact is they don't even try it
fantasy i think they probably pay for
sites
i not only worked hard i worked the
hardest i possibly could i could not
have worked harder
at my league and my team
it just
it was a disaster from the get-go i um
i drafted fitzpatrick and as one of my
quarterbacks 2qb league and then after
the first game against miami last season
i dropped him i was like he's going to
be no good of course he went on to score
40 points a game and i couldn't get him
back
it was just a disaster from the get-go
hey man for sure that the jets last
season i am from new york we're going to
have an amazing season so i drafted
levien in the third round he played a
total of three quarters last season the
entire season not only on the jets but
on the chiefs as well
it was um
it was a disaster season i came in last
and it it
it changed me as a person
and i have to say i realized it all came
rushing back yesterday when i went up
against someone who played gronkowski
who i believe was one of the last picks
in our league
and he
put up two touchdowns i don't think i
can do this another year my kids are
right why do i play fantasy football if
it upsets me too much i stop and i think
when did fantasy football really make me
happy last season i won one
[Music]
week by like a point two you know and
that didn't even make me that happy i
thought to myself oh why did i only win
by point two i should have won by more
oh i missed this person in the flex i
i'm never happy jerry doesn't make me
happy jerry when the losses when the
losses hurt more than the wins give you
enjoyment that's when it's time to
retire but you know look let's let's see
how this year plays out and you know i i
i want to talk about your show so your
people don't get upset with me or you
for just talking about right you know
i'm on the talk yes um our big season
premieres uh monday we're doing a uh
like a barbecue like a block party yes
it's um it's super fun um it's live uh
i've entered the world of uh talk show
host mister isaac
tips for me yeah i'll be great at it i
know you've got you got akbar there's
akbar amanda klutz cheryl underwood
there's you the talk on cbs 2 3
we're trying to do something a little
different on in daytime where we have uh
a couple of uh
dudes up here not that we identify
people strictly through their gender
um
we're trying something different it's a
really good group of people working here
i'm uh
i'm excited to uh come to work every day
and you know what it's like a real old
school live
tv show you know i mean
it's uh
we come in we do it for an hour and then
whatever we said that's it we left it on
the studio floor it's um it's exciting
it's it's a new thing for me at mr jerry
oc on both twitter and instagram let's
talk how about this let's you and i talk
i do have to say i give a lot of places
especially here in southern california
yelp reviews if i have a good experience
in a place you can follow me on yelp
there's no way to mine
a way to monetize it but
i just do it it's like a good thing to
do if i have a good experience somewhere
i just leave a good yelp review no okay
well for the show
leave one well i don't do it are we on
yelp yeah but we could be you're you're
in charge of social media
i gotta say uh this has been such a
positive experience
jerry hopefully could help me with my
uber rating but that'll be for our next
conversation
that'll be that'll be for our next
conversation uh well let's let's chat in
like a month we'll we'll talk more about
your show and how your your team let's
do it let's prayers up i need latavius
murray to get 25 points on monday
hopefully that will happen oh my gosh
jerry o'connell take care of yourself
man
best of luck jerry o'connell the one and
only wow oh i haven't spoken in a while
that was fun i'm laughing my ass off
that was funny at mr jerry oc on twitter
and instagram that was jerry o'connell
on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here